terry bradshaw war number 12. aaron
rodgers where's number 12. we played
earlier today on pft live the clip of
bradshaw from moose and maggie on wfan
where brad shaw went in on aaron rodgers
regarding the way he's handling the
green bay packers
terry bradshaw realizing that
taking on aaron rodgers could be good
for business he's on today with colin
coward and his name is trending on
twitter here's terry bradshaw earlier
today with more criticism of the
reluctant packers quarterback
while aaron rodgers is phenomenal look
he's an incredible player but i could
sit here and tell you right now he has
probably uh the worst footwork i've ever
seen for starting quarterback
i mean
but
i was talking to uh
john zarnicki this morning
and i said
he's an amazingly accurate he protects
the football he puts up monster numbers
but his footwork is all over the place
and i don't know if that's because he
got hit a lot he's
out of position and doesn't trust his
lineman very seldom steps into a throat
pretty impressive actually but i do
believe they are
they are
a little bit pampered a lot of coaches
uh
would say
you know what he deserves to be pampered
he's this he's that and i say look you
signed the contract you've got a couple
of years left on that if you want to be
like tom brady play out your contract
and then move on but in this case you
can't force aaron rodgers coddle maybe
too much he has no right to want to get
the gm fired what right does he have no
more right than i have to call eric
shanks and say tear my contract up i had
a really good year and you go well
you've got four years left on it
yeah but i had a really good
there's a lot there
there's a lot there i want to start at
the end and work my way backward to the
extent i remember the stuff that will be
on the back end
remember with nfl players there are two
contracts that govern the relationship
with the team the individual contract
with the organization and the broader
contract between the union and the
league and the player has rights under
both contracts and the player has
mechanisms for exerting leverage has a
right to not show up for training camp
if he's willing to suffer the financial
consequences so
you can
you can
as an nfl player
take advantage of certain rights that
you have under the cba now if you're a
rookie with fewer than three years in
the nfl you got no rights because
there's nothing you can do to get a new
contract but for a guy like aaron
rodgers there are things you can do so i
just want to start right there and say
let's not get this twisted because this
is broader than the contract that aaron
rodgers has
with the green bay packers now now
it's true
he'd have a hell of a lot more leverage
if his contract expired like tom brady's
did and it's true that aaron rodgers
always grabs the bag as the kids say and
signs a long-term deal that puts him
under contract with the packers for
multiple years into the future and he's
got three more years so
yes he is under contract and yes that is
part of the leverage the packers have
but this is very different sharing than
the individual contract that a terry
bradshaw would have with fox because
there's no broader union contract that
terry bradshaw could rely upon to give
him rights to try to force the packers
to do something they don't want to do
mike this is why i love you because
you're so good at breaking down the
legal stuff and the contract stuff and
it's just another example of that you're
exactly right let's just remember too
the error that
that terry bradshaw played in the 1970s
there was no free agency right and it
was called the no trade league back then
because they didn't make trades
quarterbacks had no leverage at that
point when terry bradshaw played they
have leveraged now they figured that out
and they're using that leverage like
they've never used it before and i think
we're seeing that in this example of
aaron rodgers and he does have leverage
despite what all these old school people
want to say he has no leverage because
he's under contract he does have
leverage he absolutely has leverage so
now it may force him to retire and pay
back the money that he owes the packers
of signing bonuses and roster bonuses
that have already been paid and you've
written a great article about that mike
44.5 million dollars he'd have to pay
back but he does have leverage let's get
that straight right now he has absolute
leverage
yes uh the world is different when it
relates to football players and tom
brady has demonstrated that and tom
brady has psychologically wrecked
multiple franchises this year by leaving
the patriots winning a super bowl with
the buccaneers and demonstrating to all
great quarterbacks out there that there
is another way i think it's a
combination of antonio brown tweeting
his way out of pittsburgh one year
and then tom brady
managing to walk out of new england with
no contract to hold them in place the
next and kind of morphed together and
it's given quarterbacks who are under
contract a realization that there are
still options that you have despite the
fact that you're under contract
where this goes for the packers and
aaron rodgers still remains to be seen i
believe firmly that this is all
strategic this is all calculated that
everything that happened last week was
something that rogers desired to have
happen
and you're starting to see reports along
the lines of well rogers didn't intend
for any of this to happen his camp
didn't like it well why in the hell
would the packers leak all of it why
would they
put out there for example that rogers
wants brian goodikunst the gm of the
team fired and then lie about the
sourcing of it that it came from rogers
camp i think all of this came from
rogers camp and i think rogers wants to
have plausible deniability i've heard
that
he's told at least one teammate i don't
know what the big deal is
now
there's a difference between hearing
that through the grapevine
and having rogers say i don't know what
the big deal is
but maybe he's just testing that out to
see how people react to it i don't buy
it i think it's too late for him to do
the steve urkel did i do that
nonsense or
you know pretend that it's not what it
is
because
he knows what's going on he sees the
reaction he liked the devonta adams
tweet
so you know we're in this holding
pattern the packers aren't going to say
or do anything right now
what's rogers going to say what's he
going to do and it will be very
disappointing if he tries to act like
this was
something that didn't happen or
something that he didn't have a spoon in
the stoo for it's too late for him to
try to walk this back it's been out
there for five days now shireen
well and it started my let's back up
even farther than that on the day after
the season ended or immediately after
the game in that follow-up press
conference when he basically laid it out
there what he wanted and it sounded like
there was some unhappiness there and
talked about the beautiful mystery of
his future and all those sorts of things
so this has been ongoing for months now
and it's kind of uh sped up over the
past few days and like you said who
knows where this is headed
i always thought aaron rodgers will
return for one more year and i think
probably that was the packers plan maybe
that not their initial plan but once he
won the mvp award i think that was their
plan and i think they're playing change
along the way but aaron rodgers may be
changing their plan along the way too
saying i don't like this i want out of
green bay but it almost seems like mike
like he wants his cake and to eat it too
like he wants to leave green bay is what
it sounds like to me but he doesn't want
the fans to hate him he wants the fans
to still like him in greek bay and
that's probably not going to be possible
i get it he didn't draft jordan love i
get that they drafted his replacement
but nonetheless this exit is not going
to be pretty and packers fans are not
going to like aaron rodgers the way this
he's exiting green bay
and you hit the nail on the head the
idea that he wants to be able to get out
of green bay without alienating the fan
base we already heard a little pandering
to the fan base on saturday after mike
tarico had spoken with rogers at the
kentucky derby paraphrased some of the
things rogers said he loves green bay he
loves the fans he loves the franchise
the fans are caught between the packers
and the quarterback and i think this is
why the packers are willing to call his
bluff they don't think he'll ultimately
put his name to it they don't think
he'll ultimately say out loud
publicly privately yes because he has
look
he's dragged him out there at least
three times to california to genuflect
to kiss the ring to kiss the ass to kiss
whatever to get aaron rodgers in a
mindset
to show up and play
and
there's no hey problem solved new
contract the new contract is the thing
that would let us know that it's problem
solved and everything's fine
so there's clearly something privately
that's been communicated that publicly
hasn't you hit the nail on the head he
doesn't want the fans to get upset with
him
uh and and that's the the strongest card
the packers have because they know
they know he's going to be very
reluctant to do that and you know i i
look i wrote something today and i fully
and firmly believe this and packers fans
are upset that i'm even pointing it out
packers fans should be upset with
everyone here they should be upset with
the packers for the way they handled the
situation
last year with jordan love
and they should be upset with aaron
rodgers for pulling the pin on the
grenade
the first day of the draft when brian
gudy kunsten and the rest of the front
office needed to be focused exclusively
on the draft you don't need this
distraction when you're trying to go out
and draft the best players you can and
make good trades and do all the things
necessary to make the team better they
don't need that headache and aaron
rodgers deliberately gave him that
headache so if i'm a packers fan
i'm i'm upset with everybody right now
shireen and uh
and and i think that aaron rodgers
already
threw five days of silence
because you you also hit the nail on the
head when you said the last time around
when this came up
after the nfc championship game what are
you doing on pat mcafee show two days
later and said oh no no no well you got
me all wrong oh no no i'm hey i'm you
know i'm see he said everything but we
could all be dead by sunday
this time around he's not going on
anywhere and he's not saying anything if
and and he's smart enough to know
how the fire is raging if he had
anything to say to walk it back he would
do it silence is deafening silence is
confirmation given these circumstances
oh there's no question i think silence
speaks to his efforts to get out of
green bay and do it graciously where
packers fans still like him and i just
don't think that's possible at this
point there's just too much in the water
right now for as you said put the
toothpaste back in the toothpaste
uh holder you just can't do it at this
point the two but you just can't do it i
mean it's out there all of this is out
there
he's going to get traded at some point
whether that's this year that this has
sped that up or next year uh when he
doesn't show up to training camp and
everything else or he plays out this
year and he's going to be traded after
this year but at some point soon mike
aaron rodgers no longer is going to be
the packers quarterback that's just
reality of this and it was reality the
day they drafted jordan love that it was
going to be his team at some point and
that timeline seems to be speeding up at
this point
i think toothpaste back in the
toothpaste holder is kind of a sims-ism
i think you've been watching too much
bft live and sims has been influencing
you i like it though i like it it is and
and and look you're right
one of the things that bothers me about
nfl fandom generally when there's a
fight between the billionaires and the
millionaires
the fans align
with the billionaires the fans align
with the team the team's always going to
be there
the players are going to come and go
and aaron rodgers is so close to the end
that yeah he's going to be gone anyway
so
they're eventually going to gravitate to
the packers nothing aaron rodgers says
or does is going to make the average
packers fan
stop being a packers fan
it's not going to happen
so you're not going to win that fight
now maybe you can pull it off the way
tom brady did
but tom brady's contract expired and tom
brady won six super bowls
he got the benefit of the doubt no one
was upset with tom brady and also
patriots fans kind of saw the team
wasn't very good and is it tom brady is
it the team you know it just it felt
like it was time for it to end 20 years
was enough
aaron rodgers doesn't have 20 years in
and he only has one super bowl win with
the packers so i think it's a it's a
different situation altogether and he is
going to risk if he isn't already
alienating fans and i think he is
alienating some
he's going to alienate more the longer
this goes and if he tries that
i didn't mean any of this i don't know
what the big deal is i haven't been
paying attention to social media i've
been you know none of that's going to
work
there's too much out there
for him to try to act like
any of it is false
and that he didn't have a hand in making
sure that it all happened when it did
the first opening night of the draft
since last year when the packers stunned
him with the jordan love selection
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports